investors seem not impressed what does
this mean for the trajectory of apple
with these new products well you know
the challenge for Apple now is they've
already set such an incredibly high bar
for themselves you know they're really
competing them against themselves it's
not about competing against Samsung and
these other guys it's against themselves
and that's getting harder and harder to
do quite honestly you know the other
challenges you've got products that are
really really good already so now you're
making some incremental improvements in
a lot of cases and at a certain point
those increments aren't necessarily
enough to get people to say oh yeah I
got to change what I've got so you know
in the case of the iphone for example I
think we'll see a lot of the people who
didn't quite make it to an iphone 6 go
all right fine now you know I can make
the move but not convinced going to see
a whole ton of people who already have a
6 move to the 6s well and and let's talk
about China here because if it doesn't
look very different I mean why show off
your friends that you have a new one
that looks like the old one well and
that's a great point and it does look
almost identical in fact frankly it does
look identical it because most of the
changes are internal you know the force
touch feature that Brad talked about is
or the 3d touch they called it it's
interesting you know it doesn't work on
every application and so some people
going to push it and it won't
necessarily do anything and that can be
a little offsetting plus the reality is
it's not going to work on of the any of
the existing iphone so application
developers have to deal with creating
special versions just for the new phone
so there's work they've got to be there
but that's why it's like yeah it's nice
but I'm not sure it changes the world
okay what about the iWatch and the Apple
pencil and the new upgrade for Apple TV
how about those are those game changers
you know the Apple watch stuff was
really nothing more than a couple other
bands and a couple of colors you know if
you like the Apple watch before you'll
still like it now if you didn't care for
the Apple watch before this is not going
to change anything the ipad pro is an
interesting product but it's really
expensive frankly it's kind of an apple
would never admit it
like their version of a microsoft
surface pro 3 s and by the time you add
the keyboard in the pencil you're up to
almost thirteen hundred dollars with the
high-end model now you know in the
pencils nice but let's be honest it's a
stylus which Steve Jobs of course swore
Apple would never do and it's a hundred
dollars and there's no case for it no
place to put it even inside the keyboard
case so people going to lose the thing
which is going to be frustrating at a
hundred dollars and it's nice for a
small niche of people the Apple TV was
actually probably the most impressive
thing of the day because it had a really
nice to interface and the touch remote
they had was pretty clever the challenge
though just to finish the thought on
that one is that how many people are
really going to cut the cord because all
of these over the set-top boxes are for
people who you know cut off traditional
satellite and cable TV services and
certainly here in the US that's a big
deal I know it's different in China